[Music]
on this monday night a covet 19 vaccine
coming sooner than expected to canada
when will it arrive and how many doses
thank god
plus the complexities of distributing a
vaccine that must be kept
ultra cold and what it means about who
would get it first
anxiety in alberta if we really try to
process everything we're going through i
think
we would break what one mayor says he's
prepared to do as pressure mounts on the
premier to impose restrictions
a covid 19 outbreak at a bc mink farm
the fears this could spawn
another public health threat and another
mystery spike it was crazy i was like oh
my god we've got one here
what's up with all these monoliths
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
canada is on the cusp of taking delivery
of the first vaccine for covid19
and it's happening earlier than
originally expected the federal
government now says the first
doses of the pfizer biontech vaccine
could arrive as early as next week
health canada hasn't approved it yet it
is still reviewing data from several
vaccine candidates
but it could approve the pfizer biontech
vaccine later this week
and the prime minister said today a deal
has been made to get up to 249
000 doses of it delivered shortly after
that
we are facing the largest immunization
in the history of our country this is no
small task
which is why we have a clear plan
pending health canada approval
the first shipment of doses is tracking
for delivery
next week
that plan depends on preparing 14
vaccination sites
sites equipped with ultra cold freezers
essential to store the pfizer vaccine
the plan is for every province to have
at least one site
the four biggest provinces quebec
ontario alberta and bc will have two
doses will be doled out to the regions
on a per capita basis
though because of the logistical
challenges of the ultracold storage the
territories
won't be part of this initial round of
the pfizer vaccine
the cold chain distribution will play a
big role in who gets the pfizer vaccine
first
it's complicated to store and requires
two doses and not
everyone will get it the initial 249 000
doses will be enough to vaccinate
about 125 000 canadians contracts have
been signed for more doses in the months
ahead not just from pfizer
but from other manufacturers and tonight
canada is closer than ever to getting
this mass
immunization program underway mercedes
stevenson has our top story tonight
today is a great day for canada and for
canadians
after weeks of mounting pressure on the
federal government
about when canadians would see a covid19
vaccine
some unexpected good news we can assure
canadians that we will have
early doses of the pfizer vaccine in
this country the light
at the end of the tunnel is clear the
relief in the provinces
clear newfoundland and labrador is one
of the 14 vaccine distribution sites
prime minister
trudeau just announced thank god
pfizer will deliver the vaccine to
ultra-cold freezers at
hospitals and universities across canada
but it is up to provinces to determine
who rolls up their sleeves first we just
need to
you know set up the expectations that
this is going to be a very limited
supply especially early on and so be
very minimal scope
on who we can immunize with it at the
front of the line in most provinces
the elderly those working in long-term
care homes
and health care providers as well as
indigenous canadians
but there could be a hiccup the pfizer
vaccine is temperature sensitive
and it's not clear whether it must be
injected at the same
site pfizer is delivering to or if it
could be transported
to long-term care homes and other
locations we're still in discussions
with pfizer to understand
whether the the doses must be
left at that initial place and then
people come to where
the vaccines are located or if there is
some ability to move the vaccine
slightly for the vulnerable elderly that
might mean waiting for the moderna
vaccine
which the company says could be ready
for delivery this month
too it also means the territories and
indigenous canadians in remote
communities
will have to wait might be a focus on
urban centers or
or places where it's more i think
amenable to having those vaccinations
take place and then as
we get more and more doses we'll be able
to offer to more and more canadians
prime minister trudeau says the first
run will give the country a vital road
map
donna pfizer and health canada are
conducting a dry run today
that includes dry ice to mimic the
procedure and try to sort out any
hitches in the plan
before the real vaccines roll out
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks administering the vaccine as
mercedes reported when it's approved and
deciding who gets it first is up to the
provinces it is clear the priority will
be frontline healthcare workers and the
most vulnerable
quebec which recorded more than 1500 new
cases for the third straight day
and has more than 800 coveted patients
in the hospital
is one of the hardest hit regions and it
unveiled its vaccination plan
today mike armstrong reports
the plan is to hit the ground running
quebec's health minister says next
monday december 14th the province will
take possession of four boxes
of pfizer vaccine about four thousand
doses they'll be delivered to two sites
one in montreal and one in quebec city
and as quickly as possible the plan is
to use those doses
to vaccinate seniors in two long-term
care facilities
that's really our first test that's
important the health minister has been
in contact with pfizer and hopes to have
a bigger shipment later this month 57
more boxes
the province's set criteria of who it
wants to vaccinate first
and age is the biggest priority that
means long-term care facilities go first
but
as that happens they're also going to be
hitting at least
some of the second group health care
workers we need to make sure we protect
the patient but we need also to make
sure that we protect the people that
work for for them once those two first
groups are done quebec's plan would be
to hit isolated communities
and then groups based on age working
down 80 and over
70 over and so on it will be a massive
effort but one the province is confident
it can pull off
quebec's already vaccinating about 250
000 people a week for influenza
it'll be months before there's enough
covet 19 vaccine
to get to that rate now quebec
hospitals are starting to be overwhelmed
the lakeshore general on montreal's west
island is
over capacity and has shut down its
emergency ward the health minister says
the province has been operating the
health care system
at about 80 percent and is cutting that
to 50.
that means turning away patients who
need treatments and operations
the restrictions in place including
banning christmas gatherings
are needed we don't want to lose the
focus despite this good news that we
have
the effect of the vaccine or getting
back to life as normal
is still a long way down the road but it
also appears this good news is arriving
as we enter what may be the toughest
stretch
of the pandemic mike armstrong global
news
montreal it's been two weeks since
tighter restrictions were introduced in
the hardest hit areas of ontario and the
virus is
still spreading ontario had a record
number of new cases reported today more
than nineteen hundred
most of the infections are in the
toronto and peel regions
which moved into lockdown on november
23rd
and in alberta the last round of
restrictions the most moderate in the
country were implemented
10 days ago there is nothing to suggest
they are working
in the past 24 hours more than 1700
albertans tested positive
and 16 more people have died on social
media today alberta's premier reaffirmed
his commitment to defend
freedom and the mayor of calgary
promised he will take action if the
province does not
as politicians talk hospitals are
dealing with the grim
reality heather urix west reports
a doctor inside this edmonton long-term
care center calls the situation inside
apocalyptic
sunday eight more deaths were tallied
associated with an outbreak
that has so far killed at least 15.
we're
crying a lot on the phone with each
other and in person as well
and feeling pretty tired and helpless at
edmonton's royal alexandra hospital
long days inside busy covid wards are
also taking a toll
i'm living 24 hours at a time if we
if i i think most of my colleagues are
the same way if we really
try to process everything we're going
through i think we would break
dr nija baxi says alberta is now facing
the kind of situation new york and italy
faced in the spring
and the fact that we've had no
significant restrictions
placed on us as a community or society
it makes it even more dire to think like
there's no ending
alberta's last round of restrictions was
announced on november
24th and took full effect on november
27th
since then the number of new infections
has risen from 1261
to 1836 sunday while the number of
people in hospital has more than
doubled i will be blunt so far we are
not
bending the curve back down alberta's
chief medical health officer says her
team
is working on new recommendations to
present to the province
on the west block sunday alberta's
health minister said new restrictions
could be coming
but perhaps not right away we did tell
albertans
that if we did not see reductions in
cases as a result of those new measures
that were
imposed that we would before december
15th
be reviewing that data with our public
health officials
and be determining whether further
measures would be required
but on social media monday alberta's
premier again pushed back against calls
for a lockdown
sharing on facebook that
constitutionally protected freedoms of
albertans must be respected and defended
and any abridgement of those rights must
be done as a last resort
not a first resort calgary's mayor says
the province needs to act
now adding that if it does not the city
is prepared to take action
my number one duty as the mayor is to
protect the health of the citizens of
calgary who put their trust in me
and whether or not i have the black line
jurisdictional authority to do that
the city will have to act without the
province but i hope it doesn't come to
that
leaving albertans waiting as covet cases
continue to rise
heather eurix west global news calgary
canada's smallest province has imposed a
two-week circuit breaker lockdown to
contain an emerging outbreak of covid19
there
four new cases were reported on pei
today
all of them in people under the age of
40. they're all a result
of close contact with three fast food
restaurant workers who tested positive
over the weekend
the circuit breaker is necessary for us
to help stop the spread of covet in our
province
certainly wasn't a decision that we
wanted to make but it was a decision
that we needed to make
restaurant dining rooms gyms and
libraries are among the facilities on
pei that will be shut down until at
least december 21st
retail stores can operate at half
capacity and gatherings are limited to
10 people
hospitals and long-term care homes will
limit access to one designated visitor
per resident in the u.s restrictions are
now being
tightened in several regions as the
number of coveted cases there
keeps rising rapidly in the first five
days of december another one million
infections were added
to the nation's staggering tally the u.s
is now on track to surpass
15 million cases by tomorrow this is
likely a surge of positive
tests after thanksgiving and there are
more holidays in the weeks ahead
health workers could be facing a tsunami
of new cases
before the first rounds of vaccinations
have even begun
jackson proskow in reno nevada
overwhelmed hospitals have had to start
providing treatment outdoors in the
parking garage
never in my wildest nightmares would i
ever have thought
that we would ever see something that
would be killing this many people
near boston a field hospital that
originally closed in may is preparing to
accept a second round of covid19
patients
it requires everyone to do the right
thing
every day if you're going to stop the
spread spread that's now
so rapid states are scrambling to bring
it under control
california logged more than 30 thousand
cases on sunday
the day before it put 85 percent of
residents under strict new stay at home
orders
that shut her restaurants for a second
time we're
a little nervous said we're not going to
make it honestly there's near universal
fear about a lack of hospital capacity
these patients are not going to stop
coming in these next few weeks
especially after we feel the effects of
thanksgiving
the worry is that surge will arrive just
as people gather again for the holidays
without substantial mitigation the
middle of january
can be a really dark time for us yet
there's near silence from the white
house
on monday president donald trump spoke
only of the positive diagnosis and
hospitalization of his personal lawyer
rudy giuliani
rudy is doing well i just spoke to him
he's doing very well in recent days
giuliani has been traveling the country
mostly massless as part of the
president's efforts to overturn the
election
his contact with arizona lawmakers has
forced that state's legislature into
recess
the virus is now so pervasive that it
will dominate trump's final 44 days in
office
by exacting an unimaginable toll on the
american people
jackson prosko global news washington
covid 19 at a canadian mink farm coming
up is a cull
coming what scientists are watching for
after that huge call of millions of mink
on farms in denmark there were fears
coveted 19 might appear in mink farms
around the world
well now it's beginning to happen an
outbreak among workers has been declared
on a mink farm in british columbia's
fraser valley
no cull of the small mammals is planned
here
but as robin gill explains the cases are
being closely watched
there are about a dozen mink farms in
british columbia
at one location there's been an outbreak
involving eight workers
and there's a reason to worry some ink
will test positive but really show no
symptoms at all and seem fine
others will be sick and some will die
and so of course it's a concern to the
farmers to try to protect their herds
the mink live in confined spaces
densely packed together and can pass the
virus onto
each other quickly but when the disease
goes beyond that
it's a bigger breeding ground going
forth and back between animals and
humans is
another opportunity for the virus to
mutate at a higher rate than if it were
to stay in one species only
take a look at what happened in denmark
the largest exporter of mink
the industry was forced to cull all 17
million of its animals
after 12 people were infected by a
mutated strain of the virus
it had passed from humans to the mink
and then back
to people if there was a new strain that
originated somewhere else
then the world would be you know
potentially
exposed to a new virus in canada there
are 60 mink farms
stretching from newfoundland and
labrador to british columbia
the business worth about 400 million
dollars annually
exports about a million mink mostly to
china and russia
to be made into apparel the industry
doesn't believe a cull is necessary
in canada you don't have that
concentration and the risk of contagion
and passing from one farm to another is
much much reduced
the owner of the bc farm is in isolation
as are the workers
the health ministry is investigating to
see what course of action
needs to be taken next robin gill global
news vancouver
contagious bride ahead the couple who
defied a diagnosis and tied the knot
nothing traditional about this wedding a
couple in india decided to go ahead with
the ceremony after the bride tested
positive for covid19
they dressed in full ppe wearing face
masks and hazmat suits and it
took place in a courtyard at a
quarantine center
the only guests were the bride's parents
and a priest
in southern india a region already
overwhelmed by covid19 a mystery illness
has sparked another health crisis
at least one person has died and 200
others are in the hospital
the symptoms range from loss of
consciousness to seizures nausea and
anxiety
it was first detected on saturday a team
of experts sent by the government
is now investigating global news has
obtained declassified intelligence
documents that detail how neo-nazis and
other extremist groups have tried to
take advantage
of the covet 19 pandemic by spreading
false information and far-right
propaganda
a secret national security brief
prepared by csis outlined attempts to
blame the pandemic
on jews china immigrants the government
and societal
elites it also examined the spread of
coveted conspiracy theories to attract
new followers
raise money and encourage violence the
report was prepared before the july 2nd
incident in ottawa when a heavily armed
man
breached the gates outside the prime
minister's residence with his pickup
truck
the suspect a military reservist from
manitoba allegedly shared conspiracy
conspiracy theories on social media
you can read more about the declassified
report on our website global news dot ca
slash global national
monolith mystery up next the latest
spike to appear
apparently out of nowhere
fans of bob dylan think his songs are
priceless but he's just sold the rights
to all of them to universal music
all 600 songs dating back 60 years the
financial terms weren't disclosed nor
the reason
dylan did it he has sold more than 125
million records throughout his career
though money never seemed to be his
metric for success he once said
what's money a man is a success if he
gets up in the morning and gets to bed
at night and
in between does what he wants to do
someone's been busy erecting mysterious
metal spikes and provoking
intrigue around the world what started
in utah has now been repeated in
multiple places including
england and the netherlands and there
are some wild theories about who put
them there
and why redmond shannon on the mystery
of the monoliths
another day another monolith this time
on the small isle of wight
in england it was crazy i was like oh my
god we've got one here
why here it's so out of the way compared
to like america
peter hodd was one of the first to come
see it early sunday
even with my own eyes it looked like it
had been edited in it was so like
surreal looking it was like
it was like a tear in fabric and time it
was just like this portal
like i said it's at the bottom of a very
stiff cliff like a very steep
drop um and the only way up and down um
you know without having to climb is this
wooden staircase and it's steep as well
it's it's
on a hell of an incline it was the same
day a similar object appeared in the
netherlands
[Music]
they're reminiscent of alien installed
monoliths from arthur c
clarke's space odyssey series and come
after
three others were discovered in recent
weeks so is it solid
not solid the first had been sitting in
a remote utah desert for about
five years the safeword has run
just over a week later it was
mysteriously removed
on the same day that this one appeared
in romania
followed by another in california
that was also torn down
only to be quickly reinstalled there are
conflicting claims as to who's behind
them
and what they all mean this amateurish
version a cheeky hoax from a candy store
owner
so how about this i wake up thursday
morning and there's a monolith that
appears right in front of my shop here
in the strip district
jumping on board what is most likely a
copycat
trend and a welcome distraction from all
things
2020 redmond shannon global news london
we need distractions that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen tonight's here canada is this
totem pole at wiscana center in regina
bc gave the totem pole to saskatchewan
as a gift back in 1971 to mark bc's
100th anniversary of becoming a province
please send us your canada to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
bye-bye
you